[Musique]
en conférence de presse serge hoareau
vice président du département délégué à
l'agriculture et l'interprofession
annonce un accord avec bruxelles sur le
maintien des fonds posei pour la réunion
le programme d'options spécifiques à
l'éloignement et à l'insularité regroupe
des mesures visant à compenser
l'éloignement géographique des régions
ultrapériphériques dans le développement
et la diversification des filières
agricoles
on vient de gagner une victoire sur l'
enveloppe poesy une enveloppe qui était
annoncé en diminution de 3 9% grâce à la
mobilisation des interprofessions que
nous avons accompagné grâce au travail
effectué par euros d'hommes et le député
européen et younousse omarjee nous avons
pu obtenir le maintien de cette
enveloppe c'est une victoire
la baisse de cette enveloppe pourrait
engendrer une perte de 25 millions
d'euros par an sur la période 2021 et
2027 se font poser y occupe une place
importante au coeur du monde agricole
réunionnais pour exemple celle de la
filière lait une partie production
laitière que l'accompagnement de la
production laitière l'autre qui qui en
contrepartie d'éléments qualitatifs
vient soutenir le prix du lait est le
troisième élément ce qui concerne le
producteur c'est le ramassage de son
lait à la collecte qui est prise en
charge pour partie en tout cas les
surcoûts de manière à alléger
ski
alléger le coût du ramassage de lait et
qui n'est pas le supporter directement
le département de la réunion et les
acteurs du monde agricole devons à
nouveau rencontrer la commission
européenne cette fois pour éviter la
baisse prévue de 7 % du feader et de ses
taux d'intervention
[Musique]